HAVE PREDICTED ON THIS SHOW
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO WE HAVE BEEN SAYING 2018
IS THE YEAR OF THE
BOOMERANG.
JOINING US NOW, THE AUTHOR
OF THE NEW PERSONAL
REVELATION, RNC SPOKESPERSON
KAYLEIGH McANNIE IS WITH
US.
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR DOUG
SCHOEN.
KAYLEIGH, START WITH YOU.
JAMES COMEY'S OWN MEMO, IF
THERE IS SOME SATELLITE, HE
TOOK IT TO MEAN ASSOCIATE OF
HIS CAMPAIGN DID SOMETHING,
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO FIND
THAT OUT.
OKAY.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE HE WANTS
THE INVESTIGATION TO BE
THOROUGH, COMPLETE, AND EVEN
IF IT'S PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
HE WANTS TO KNOW WHO DID
WHAT, AND AFTER A YEAR PLUS,
WE HAVE NOTHING.
>> RIGHT, SEAN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE
OPPOSITE OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A PRESIDENT
FULLY COOPERATING WITH THE
INVESTIGATION AND TO ECHO
THAT JAMES COMEY SAYS IN HIS
BOOK THAT NONE OF HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT ROSE TO THE LEVEL
OF ILLEGALITY.
THERE IS NO THERE THERE TO,
QUOTE:  PETER STRZOK.
THERE IS NO THERE THERE WITH
COLLUSION.
OBSTRUCTION.
HE HAS BEEN CLEARED BY THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
ROBERT MUELLER SAID YOU ARE
NOT A TARGET OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
ROD ROSENSTEIN HAS SAID IT
AND IN COMEY'S MEMO SAYS TO
THE PRESIDENT THREE TIMES
YOU ARE NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS
COOPERATED.
HE SHOULD BE ABSOLVED AND
ROBERT MUELLER NEEDS TO PACK
UP, GO HOME, MOVE ON.
>> Sean: THINK OF THE WEEK
HAD YOU, DR. GORKA YOU HAD
THE CONGRESSIONAL CRIMINAL
REFERRALS, HILLARY CLINTON,
LORETTA LYNCH, STRZOK, PAGE,
COMEY, MCCABE, ANYBODY
INVOLVED IN THE DOSSIER.
CRIMINAL REFERRAL BY THE IG
AS IT RELATES TO ANDREW
MCCABE.
NOW TODAY WE HAVE JAMES
COMEY HIMSELF.
HE IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
EVERYTHING -- YOU WERE PART
OF PREDICTING AS I WAS THAT
THIS IS ALL GOING TO BACK
FIRE ON THEM BECAUSE THE
VERY THING THEY WERE
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF
THEY THEMSELVES ARE GUILTY
OF.
WHAT A WEEK IT'S BEEN.
>> YOU READ THE PARTS OF THE
DECLASSIFIED MEMOS TODAY.
JAMES COMEY SAYS THAT HE
SAID I DON'T DO WEASEL
MOVES.
I DON'T MAKE SLIMY TRICKS.
WELL, GUESS WHAT, HE IS ONE
6'7" SLIMY WEASEL.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
IF YOU READ, THIS WHAT DO WE
NOW KNOW, SEAN?
WE TOLD KNOW HE TOLD THE
PRESIDENT YOU'RE NOIFT THE
TARGET.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT TOLD
HIM I WANT A CLEAN BILL OF
HEALTH FOR MY WHOLE
CAMPAIGN, GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
JAMES COMEY REFUSED TO MAKE
A PUBLIC STATEMENT TO THE
AFFECT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT THE TARGET AND THAT HE
WANTS A CLEAN BILL OF HEALTH
BUT WHAT DID HE DO?
HE LEAKED THE FALLACIOUS
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
ACCUSATIONS THAT HE TOLD
CONGRESS LATER WERE
UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS.
THAT'S WHAT HE GAVE TO THE
PRESS.
HOW IS THAT NOT BIASED,
SEAN?
>> Sean: KNOW, I'M WATCHING
THE DEMOCRATS TODAY, THE
WHOLE RUSSIA COLLUSION
NARRATIVE IS FALLING APART,
DOUG.
THE WHOLE THING.
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO FILE A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT, PROBABLY
GO JUDGE SHOPPING AND I HOPE
THEY GET A LIBERAL JUDGE
AFTER THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS KEY THIS
WEEK.
HE TOLDETH PRESIDENT HE IS
NOT THE TARGET IN EITHER
INVESTIGATION THE ONE IN NEW
YORK OR THE ROBERT MUELLER
SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING
THEY NEVER FOUND ANY
EVIDENCE OF ANY TYPE OF
COLLUSION.
AND FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THEY CAN'T LET IT GO
THAT NOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
THEIR ISSUE GOING INTO 2018?
SOUNDS LIKE A BAD IDEA TO
ME.
>> WELL, SEAN, IT'S NOT ONLY
YOU AND REPUBLICANS WHO
THINK IT'S A BAD IDEA,
PEOPLE LIKE CONGRESS WOJ
JACKIE EXPIRE FROM
CALIFORNIA SAID THIS IS
TRYING TO OVERTLY POLITICIZE
AN INVESTIGATION THAT HAS
NOT YET BEEN COMPLETE YOU
HAD.
AS OF NOW WE HAVE NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO TRY TO
TURN IT INTO A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL IN THE MIDST OF AN
ELECTION CAMPAIGN RUNS THE
RISK OF A BACK FIRE AND IS
OVERWHEELCHAIRING.
WE SAW THAT
WE -AW THAT
WE --W THAT
WE -- OTHAT
WE -- OVEAT
WE -- OVERREACHING.
WE SAW THAT BEFORE WHEN
OVERREACHED.
I WOULD URGE MY FELLOW
DEMOCRATS NOT TO MAKE THE
SAME MISTAKE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE DEEP STATE
ACTORS, SEBASTIAN, YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT
THIS.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THEM,
THE IDEA THAT HILLARY
CLINTON, WE KNOW SHE
COMMITTED FELONIES AND WE
KNOW THERE WAS AN
EXONERATION BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEY USED
THE PHONY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER CREATED BY
A FOREIGN AGENT USING RUSSIA
GOVERNMENT SOURCES AND THEN
USED THAT AS A BASIS AS A
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
AMERICANS.
IT SEEMS THESE THINGS NOW,
THIS IS WHAT AMERICA IS
GOING TO FOCUS ON.
AMERICANS BELIEVE IN THE
RIGHT OF PRIVACY AND THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IN FRIVOLOUS
WARRANTS BASED ON POLITICAL
OPPONENTS PAYING FOREIGN
SOURCES THAT USE RUSSIAN
SOURCES TO LIE TO COURTS TO
GET WARRANTS TO SPY ON